mmm-hmm this game just came out I have
no clue what this is gonna be about can
someone explain to me what is happening
oh it can move I am still very very very
very confused come on flip over your
[ __ ] toast ah whoa
justice oh my god get that jelly come on
how does one apply jelly I should ask my
haters that apply the jelly you son of a
[ __ ] Erica that's that's some nice
[ __ ] jelly oh yes oh yes oh god
toast toast no toast calm down toast
dammit toast what did you do I'm a toast
from hell apparently that's oh we made
it we made it out of love
Thanks what all right
ah I'm not gonna die here it's not a
skateboard I don't know why but we're
skateboarding I never realized how much
I wanted to be a skateboarding toaster
before until I play this game it's
really challenge your perspective in
life how does one control a skateboard
as a toast let's go to new adventures
I'm better on a skateboard as a toast
than in real life how do I get off this
car go up climb that wall like your what
are you doing toast oh my god I need to
charge my crib
this is redonkulous and donkeys aren't
even born in this universe wow this is
one step for toast and a toast for toast
yes we're gonna make it I've never been
this happy in my life all right we need
some apple toast
why am i losing health what's wrong with
our Poulter's what's wrong with apple
juice all right you know what [ __ ]
everything okay I am a delicious toast
just like my mom told me that one time
and it got weird go skateboard gear
skated what are you doing stupid that's
how we stupid Oh God Edgar just farted
the worst fart of my life all right
dammit all right we got to make it up
before the grip runs out
ha ha I'm Bear Grylls as a toast the
spirit of group Bear Grylls is living in
this toast
how will the hell would I get I got it
never mind
where's the [ __ ] toaster hump the
tower hump the tower yes I'm the boss
why am I losing at ability I'm delicious
she didn't like adding stuff on top of
me Oh God that that looks good what how
am I not a toast don't you see the
flying eggs oh my god the game doesn't
understand its own game oh god what
happened
Oh God I'm a demon chose what what is
happening help Mom I'm toasting myself
okay we got to make it up before the
bread yeah I swear to God if you fall
you're testing me aren't you
mitosis mitosis how am I losing
deliciousness I'm so fabulous Hey
God stop stop bread bread bread you need
to bread it up man Brad can I call you
Brad Brad this is not your destiny to do
what you've been doing my mom told me I
would do great things in my life I don't
think this is game is what she meant
something oddly sexual about this game
yes Josh just power it up Josh what do i
do up here what am i doing okay all
right we need to make it to the toaster
there it is I can see it all right if we
can make it down there it should be fine
there we go I have a lot of power for a
toast
I don't know plates broke Oh God Oh No
oh my god oh my god just turn my hair
into the 80s that's great no one said it
was gonna be easy
no one said toast toast themselves
science may have told us that but so
[ __ ] chocolate ass what
[Music]
did cinnamon toast can predict this game
50 years in the future oh god I'm gonna
die
oh god I'm way what are you doing no no
no no no well I guess we do this again
who gave this bread its soul who is
responsible don't give bread souls
i-i've told people for many years and
there this one just goats off and on a
skateboard yes this is how you
skateboard my mom has taught me yes yes
yes yes [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
life's not fair life's not fair she
loves me bread we're never gonna give up
never gonna let you down never gonna run
around and be a bread well I guess that
doesn't apply to this game doesn't it I
keep getting stuck on these [ __ ]
ledges it's pisses me off beyond bread
man ah suck on the ledge again ah suck
up the ledge again right this is it this
is my rebecca black [ __ ] the [ __ ] i
[ __ ] up oh god oh god please have
mercy oh god that really looks like a
penis yeah what what who the hell keeps
their toaster that far away from the
bread anyway I mean that's just
ridiculous
oh my god bros we're almost there huh
we will champion we mail be the champion
wedgie oh yes I can feel it
ah yes it smells very nice too actually
oh my god did you see that I tapped out
because my recording sucked
I want to thank Oprah I want to thank
bread bread bread bread
you don't know bread bread bread bread
that's like my favorite youtuber bread
bread oh it got it it's not even plugged
in what is this go in go in go inside do
I have to shove you in myself is that
what you want me to do just push it in
you wouldn't like that
you come on toast just come on just just
do this for me please
I wonder what my neighbor is thinking
when they hear this [ __ ]
what I can't even throw myself in why
don't you love me why hey hey hey yeah
hey yeah hey hey hey ah it's toasting
it's toasting my balls off I love it
yours give it to me toast yes I feels
good
did I [ __ ] tell you to stop I never
really fully appreciate that oh god
that's terrible
oh god oh listen to it oh god no no no
no oh god we almost fell in the cat
litter no no don't go there
you don't want to go there buddy you
don't want to go there buddy trust me
when I sit okay okay okay okay careful
why the [ __ ] is there a dead body in
there I swear to my dead cat oh no no no
no please please no you are my only
friend toast
all right well like I guess we'll just
oh my god where I'd have my dad Donal oh
I am a [ __ ] toast Oh suck on that you
[ __ ] toast haters hey I know who you
are they should make the new Lord of the
Rings movies after in this game an epic
journey of someone who's a little [ __ ]
I mean let's be honest here I don't even
know what I'm doing I literally have no
[ __ ] clue that's new whoa hang on to
your life hang on to your dear life okay
okay ah ah oh oh yeah I just peed a
little bit
I just [ __ ] Peter loved it get toast
or die trying those were the words of my
my universe okay
we meet again mr. toaster
no mr. toaster you will not go to space
so if it's one of those wireless
toasters because everyone needs that
that's a genius idea
oh my god get in slide in you son of a
[ __ ] slide the [ __ ] how do you get
in the [ __ ] toaster how how how how
how how how how I'm gonna try to flip it
back okay alright I'm getting too
toasted doesn't matter doesn't murder ah
needs improvement no it doesn't that was
I am bread a game about being toast and
yeah that's great well played the next
level in the science future thank you
guys for watching hit like to become a
pro I don't know that's not that it
works do what everyone stay awesome bros
i love you
[Music]